Yeah, she **** at me.
How are you?
Good, how are you?
Okay, okay.
Nice.
Yeah.
There she is.
Hello!
Hey, Sofia.
Hello?
How's it going?
Good afternoon, Sophia.
Good, and you?
Perfectly fine.
Nice.
So before we start off, Sophia and Tammy, we have Akit with us. So Akit is working with IT by Design as a senior technical team lead and he will be helping us with the overall management of this partnership going forward. So he'll be a frequent visitor on these service calls.
Okay.
Speeding again.
Rick.
Right. So starting on a positive note, thank you so much, Sophia, for sharing the positive C side for Sally. Really appreciate that. Tammy, thank you so much for you too for sharing your feedback for Krishna. Really appreciate it.
Kip.
Let us quickly start with Sally first. So, Sophia, over to you, how she's doing.
We have encountered some issues with the payment application. She's not following the remittance. Fortunately, it's on June, so I was able to fix it, but that's something that she needs to pay more attention than that. And the second thing is that
I think that she needs a lot of supervision. So this week, I have been asking her, hey, we have tickets, work in the board. Hey, do this, do that, because it seems that she just finished the payment application and that's it.
And she needs to keep checking and because at the beginning of the month, we received a lot of billing inquiries. And I'm working on collection, so I'm not looking on the board. But when I come back, she's not working on it. So that is something that she needs to understand that both things has to be done
in the with the same precision that she's doing with payment application.
Yeah, so payment application is is doing is doing fine.
Yes, we just have few errors, but it's normal. Just need to pay more attention to the things and that's it.
Okay, how about the report that Tammy pulls at 1 every Friday? Was she able to complete all the entries on time?
Yes.
Rick.
Ohh, we gotta do that. Sorry about that.
Oh, you forgot to say.
Yeah, I have, I just, it's because the tenant came on board, so I'm busy with the appeals, the customers, the AP, so it's sort of a...
Well, a lot on my plate, let's just say that, so I do forget, so I apologize. I forgot.
No, no, it's completely fine, I will do.
I'll get it, yeah, I'll get it, yeah.
Hey, Manan.
Oh.
Hello, how are you guys?
Hello!
Hello.
I'm good.
We are good.
Good.
Singh.
Perfect. Okay, so what's the agenda today?
So we are discussing about the performance of Sally and Krishna.
Mhm.
Yep, so we have just covered Sally's part and now we are over to Krishna. So for Krishna, timing over to you.
Perfect.
Mhm.
Vishal, so this week she worked on.
I'm sorry, Tanya. I would like to intervene first. Okay. So maybe you already mentioned it, but it seems that you notified Krishna that her end date would be June 30th. Okay. I would like to know what you told her because she reached out to Tanya. She seems surprised.
Sure, yeah, yeah.
Yep.
We gave you a heads up a long time ago. I was not involved. It was more Reid. Okay. So I would like to know what was what you told her. Okay. And just make sure that the remaining of the time with us will be working and that she will be okay.
S.
So...
Yeah, sure. So we had a word with Krishna yesterday. So there we told her that June 30th will be her last working day with MSP call. So she's aware of it. We did not tell her in the initial phase because we did not want that news to impact her performance in any form.
No.
Mhm.
Mhm, understood.
Yep, so which is why we chose the mid of this month to break this news.
OK, perfect. I would appreciate to have a heads up because Tanya was surprised with the note she received from Krishna. So I just want to clarify that. I also reached out to Karine because I was a bit surprised that we received this like that. OK.
And that's why I wanted to know exactly what she was she was told. OK, so was she OK? How did she react?
No, she was surprised, obviously, but we were able to explain the reason behind what Ray partly told us, because I think two of the resources were returned from their maternity, which is why we had resource redundancy. So that's why she had to be off boarded. So yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yes, exactly.
Mhm.
Okay, perfect. Okay, so perfect. So awesome, great. So now we can still talk about her performance. So Tammy is more working closely with her. So Tammy, but I just wanted to hear the air and making sure that it would.
You will like.
Yeah.
It would be easy for Tammy if Krishna reached out to us again that we know what you said, so it's easier for us to manage. So go ahead then.
Appreciate it.
Okay, okay, so this week she worked on the checks very well, the vendor board.
What if they had got what she had working on?
Track, tracking numbers.
Tracking number, thank you, yes, the tracking number, so, and no complaints there.
We gave her additional tasks to help Sarah out with the tracking numbers and the serial numbers and then no issues. So she did what we asked her to do.
All right.
Yeah, thanks, Sofia.
That's great.
My mom is jungle, my mom is jungle, yeah.
Yeah.
It's all right. Thank you so much, Tammy and Sophia. And thank you so much, Manan, for interviewing and, you know, hearing the updates. Yeah, thank you.
Perfect. Awesome.
Let me quickly go ahead and share my screen. We have data for, yes.
Up.
Sorry, before you, we do that, Manu, I just want to share with you what I said from Sally, is that we have minor errors in the payment application, but it is understandable. The only thing that I have seen this week is that she still needs a lot of supervision.
Yes.
Mm-hmm.
and follow-ups that I have to say, hey, you have to keep looking. You are not doing this, do this, and things like that.
Yeah.
Okay, perfect. Okay, thank you for raising that. So I don't think it's the first time you discussed that at this meeting. So what would be the plan so we can help Sally improving on that?
Hello?
OK, OK, then yeah.
Yeah, sure. So we'll be working closely with Sally to understand that, you know, she's reaching out to Sophia in case she needs any assistance. But when she's done with the current assigned task, she will proactively reach out to Sophia to let her know that she has completed the task so that she can have her hands on the upcoming or the next task.
Mhm.
Understood, but if Sophia already gave her task, but she's not validating if there's some still outstanding items, technically Sophia shall not follow up on that. So that's why we're trying to resolve. It seems that she knows what to do, but she doesn't go and see.
So.
We can.
Oh, this is not done. I should do this because this is part of my responsibility. That's what we want to address.
We can proactively check with Sally if there is anything pending that she needs to work on. Or because this is something that I would rely on Sally because she would have visibility, the work that she has to do. We have a Team channel open with Sophia and Tammy.
Mhm.
So probably I can get some updates there, you know, if this is what Sally's day plan looks like, so that I can keep a tab on it and I can progressively check with Sally if she had performed those tasks or not.
Perfect. Thank you. Sophia, because we did speak for the last three weeks, so I'm so busy right now, but I wanted to take the time today. So if we, you can give some example of things like that. So for me also to understand and
helping you also on our side maybe and with Tammy building a list so it's clear for her that when this is done she needs to re-loop. Okay is it is it because she doesn't re-loop when she's done with something? Okay.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, the thing is that at the beginning of the month, we receive a lot of questions, billing questions. So the board is getting a lot of tickets, new tickets all the time. Yeah, at the end of the month, we don't receive billing questions, but we have the bosses. So that is.
that she has to manage her time, her task, because she doesn't have a lot of deposit at the beginning, but billing questions. And what I see is that she finished doing the deposits and doesn't take the time to review again the work. She works once and I have to go back and say, hey.
Review the board because we have more tickets. We have more tickets. Keep checking because the beginning is like that. We have the request is a lot because of the invoices.
Okay, well I will instruct her to refresh the board periodically. If any new entry or a new ticket work comes in, she will jump on it and work on it.
Yes, I mean, so you have a you have your hand raised.
Yeah, hey Manan, I don't know if you remember me or not, but we met.
Yes.
Yeah, so I met you with I think Isabel in the very starting when we started hiring and Karine and me, right, and I started this and I joined this call just wanted to understand from the team this I can help, right? And I have Gautam who leads my internal finance team. He is my head of finances, right?
Yeah.
I believe me, yeah.
So a question probably to you, Sophie, an open-ended question, probably I'm not the finance guy, I'm a service delivery guy. So is she lacking on the process or is she lacking on her finance skills? That's a question I wanted to ask here. Is she asking the repeated question on the process or is she not able to catch on the tickets or time sheet entries?
Or time management, right? We can, we can train her up, right? I have an around 12 people team internally as well, which Gautam leads, right? Where he leads, I think, FPNA team, finance, lead finance controller, so APAR, everything, right? So, if you can just guide us, just...
It's APAR billing out.
bless us that where is she is lacking. Is it on the time management? Is it on the tools? Or is it actually in the financial side?
Okay, I will say that is time management and tools. She knows, I have explained several times how to find information. The thing is that we cannot have like a manual, so she can guide it because every question is different from each client. They have.
different questions that number of users or what is this about, where is the quote for that, things like that. And she needs to understand where to find the information. So I have explained to her how to go from this point to that one to find information or go this part.
to the other side because we have to look like that to answer these questions. But it seems that she still doesn't understand how is the flow of the process to see where she has to find the information.
Fair enough. Gaurav, any question you have in mind, like...
So, okay, so she's not able to find the relevant information to complete her analysis or reconciliation or the task is what you're saying.
Billing questions, billing questions, yes.
No.
OK, yes, we can. We can definitely work on that. Sameer, yes, we can do.
We can help.
Train her how to find information and where to find.
We can definitely do that.
Yeah, yeah, so that's concerning, right? So we will take it up, Sophia and Manan. I will have her getting some coaching and done internally as well. Just keep us surprised wherever you see that on a daily activity where she's lacking, maybe Tammy or you, Sophia. Right, we do have the Teams channel as well, which is open at both the ends. Keith will be locally present there. Me and Gautam, we are present within India, but at another site, but we'll keep on helping.
now. So she will get the guidance and the next steps as well from Gautam. I'll make sure that she gets the full support from him as well. So he'll be available as a point of contact as well internally. And I'll foresee that I want her to be back on track. Like I heard from the team that she was good, but again I hear that there are some concerns coming back with.
It's A repeated issue. I don't want you to train her up, go on again in the cycle. So that's why she will get the full support in terms of team here.
Thank you.
Okay, yeah.
Perfect. Great.
Yeah, Ashish, over to you, you were running the call, sorry.
Yeah.
Yep, no, no, it's completely fine. Any other questions or suggestions, Sophia, on your site?
No, I think that if she is able to find the information, will help me a lot. So I don't have to be in the call with her 30 minutes to make her understand how to look at it.
Even I had this conversation with Sally. So this tool, ConnectWise Management, so she is new to it. It is indeed a very vast tool, although the steps that she followed, the methods she used in the past to discover the ticket entries, smaller segment of the tickets, she is able to uncover it.
but still there is a lot to do. So I think this is where she is, you know, stuck at. So don't worry, we'll take care of that part.
Mhm.
Thank you.
Vaid.
You're welcome.
Perfect.
That being said, I'll quickly go ahead and share my screen.
Please let me know once you're able to see it.
Is it possible?
We can see it, yes.
It is, it is.
Thank you. So first we have data for Krishna. This is from the duration June 4th till June 10th, where she worked on 81 vendor tickets, which were processed and she should close 69 of them. During this period, she had 52 tickets that had linked closure, 17 additional
POs and invoices. The peak day that she worked on was June 5th, where she worked on 17 vendor board items, out of which 15 tickets, 15 were ticket related and two were PO invoices.
And the rest of the days, the world curve was for invoice closures, vendor follow-ups, active cases calls, yep, and this is it.
I hope this matches Krishna's data at your end, Tammy.
Yeah.
Yes, yep.
Thank you.
Move on to Sally's data. So she was able to close 143 tickets in this period, out of which 98 were QuickBooks payment applications, 51 connect wise tickets, 11 queries, and six getting credit card payments. Her peak days were...
was June 4, where she resolved for 40 linked ticket items, 31 quick book payment application, 5 credit card payments, 3 connect wise ticket closures, one query resolution.
And rest of the day, she worked on QuickBooks payment applications, ConnectWise, query, and payment processing.
Yes, it seems right.
Thank you.
That being said, I will share my screen.
This is I have in terms of the data presentation for Sally and Krishna.
So, yeah, before we call it the meeting, any other feedback?
No.
So, we sent everything from the site.
No, I think that we have a we have task ahead of us, right? ITBD team. I have, that's why I have added Gautam and use, so Manan, you see more people today added on the call because I heard it. There is a repeated issue. It works well for some time, but there is there is something that we need to fix at our end, so that's why I'm here on the call today and you will see her getting better, Sophia. That's my promise to you within like...
Eventually, with the next two or three weeks, right, you will see it performing well and lesser questions and lesser repeated question to you guys.
That, that, that's what I can expect to do.
S.
Great, perfect.
Okay.
Right. I, if I'm not wrong, her core expertise is more on the GL accounting side, right? If I remember right way. What is a day in, day out, Sophia? Probably, if you can just tell me more, like, is it pure billing what she's doing as of now?
Yes.
I know, it's payment application. So we receive the payments from the client and she goes QuickBooks, find the client, find invoice, apply the payment.
Got it, got it. Now I have the clarity. Gautam, anything that you want to ask?
Yes, no, no, no, that helps. Thanks for asking that, Sameer. Yes, that helps me get a better understanding. We can definitely work on training her, and you will definitely see the improvement on her.
Yeah, then, yeah.
The difficulty is, it's working in both systems. So technically, all the communication from operation and client goes through kind of wise first. OK, but the and you need to go and pull out the information from the bank account or all the credit card provider that we have that's here pulling out the report.
Yeah, I...
Conner voice.
Play.
And then with this, you need to make sure that you apply it correctly. And the way the system work, it's applied from QuickBooks to ConnectWise, but the invoice come from ConnectWise to QuickBooks. So there's many ways and place to find the information. So that's for sure we have.
Popkin.
But I think, Sophia, you provide her the credit card statement so she doesn't have to chase them. So you have the information. She just needs to take them and take them in QuickBooks. The same thing for our bank statement.
we pull out all the transaction from the bank and she just have to enter it in QuickBooks. So it's technically really, really, really basic accounting stuff, a task to be done at the accounting level. It's, you know, in our world is complicated. Don't get me wrong, Sonia.
Mhm.
But because there's complexity of the number of the system that we have, okay, but technically it's still just an apply. And the other task, I don't know, Tammy, if you mandated or with that, but also.
to apply or to resolve all the, because we have a lot of invoices that doesn't match and 100%. Sometimes you have one cent or two cent difference and we need to write it off. So did she start doing it?
Hello.
I saw it to Sofia, yes, yeah.
Yes.
Okay, okay, perfect. So is it working well for that?
I hope so.
So far, yes. Yes.
OK, perfect. So, OK, but yeah, so, but you see, it's variation on the same, on the same teams, if you wish. So, it's this, it's always the same thing, but different because it's this credit card, this client, this location, this states, this province, this, this.
Yeah.
Yes.
But at the end of the day, it's all the way in.
She falls.
I thought that it was me.
Yep, she could.
Okay, we lost you for a few minutes. Okay, perfect. Okay, so perfect. So let's monitor that, okay. And we talked a bit about Krishna because she was made aware yesterday or earlier this week that her mandate will terminate at the end of the month.
Oh, you there, yeah.
Yeah.
Photo.
So she reached out to us. Like I said, I would have loved to know before that you would announce that to her because she's reached out to Tammy. Tammy was surprised. So we need to avoid those things.
That's on us, Manan. That's, that's on us. We should have done better, right? She should have been informed earlier. I thought that the team has done it, but that's on us, so...
Mhm.
Mm.
That's fine. It just, I would have loved at least that you tell us, oh, okay, by the way, we will advise Krishna tomorrow. So if she react or she reach out to us, we know what to do. Because she was advised yesterday, she seemed, she sent a team chat to Damian and say, oh, I just learned that my contract's terminating at the end of the month. So it just that.
Yeah.
I.
It would have been nice to know in advance. OK, so that's what I'm saying. OK.
Absolutely. No, I absolutely agree. I absolutely agree. I'll take care of it, right? And I'll make sure that he still stays with us. I'm working with Gautam so that she does not lose the job and she still remains happy and intact, right?
Okay.
Out some too, I think she she have potential. Uh, we we agree our our system is not easy the way we're set up right now, as Tanya, Satyaveer, as anybody in the teams, uh, but...
Yep.
Mm.
No, I heard as soon as you told me, Mary, you know, one side you have the QuickBooks, then you have the ConnectWise, these two integrations. So Gautam, this is exactly like where you work, right? Similar sort of setup. Also, we're an ITBD as well, Manan, we have the same sort of setup. So I know that where you guys struggle.
Yep, yep.
Yeah, so...
And it takes sometimes it is institutional knowledge as well that a person needs, I guess, right?
Yes.
So, and when you have people from Mad Leaf coming back earlier than Lang, but and they have the experience, by now we have no choice also, so, so perfect. So, we hope you can keep her. I think she, she's somebody that can improve A lot.
Yeah.
Mm.
And.
You.
No, I agree.
No, we will, we will definitely try.
And she improved a lot since she's been with us. She's young, but she may be a better on there, a more controlled environment would be easier for her to grow, get the expertise she needs, and then go on complex structure if you wish.
Yeah, no, no problem. Yeah, we will take care of her. Don't worry, yeah.
Perfect.
Perfect. Me, I need to run. So if you have other stuff to discuss, I will leave you with the stuff here in timing. So it was nice to see you all again. Thank you. Have a good afternoon. Thanks. Bye. Bye.
Thank you. Bye. Thank you, Team.
Thank you, Manan. Cheers.
Thank you, everyone.